president Trump hitting back hard
against Democrat Joaquin Castro for
outing campaign donors Trump going after
the congressman on Twitter saying I
don't know who walking Castro is other
than the lesser brother of a failed
presidential candidate 1% who makes a
fool of himself every time he opens his
mouth Joaquin is not the man that his
brother is but his brother according to
most is not much
keep fighting Joaquin despite the
backlash Castro is still not backing
down after defending his actions I don't
want anybody harassed or tart they will
be because you put their names on in
public like that that was not my
intention but that these things are
these things are public no what I would
like for them to do is think twice about
supporting a guy who is fueling hate in
this country this controversy now
raising a big question is there a double
standard when it comes to claims of
social media bias while congressman
Castro was tweeting to shame Trump
supporters Mitch McConnell's campaign
got temporarily locked out of Twitter
and it happened after posting a video
showing protesters making threats
outside of his home before the account
was restored McConnell's campaign
managers saying Twitter will allow the
words of massacre Mitch to trend
nationally on their platform but locks
our account out for posting actual
threats against us and that does seem
like a double standard Greg it certainly
does Dana what would you like to say
that's all I have to say okay the
interesting thing that I picked up from
Castro was when he said I had no
intention but maybe people will think
twice and what he's saying is think
twice because this could happen to you
he's saying hey my hand turn on this I
had nothing to do with this but maybe
you want to think twice I mean that's
really sinister stuff
I call it tertiary tertiary thuggery
where he directs the people to commit to
do the dirty work while he's so far he's
like the logistics guy who tells the
goons where to go he hands me he writes
the addresses down on a piece of paper
and he slips it over to the guy for bid
some happy just gave me some accident it
has nothing to do with with me at all
but anyway this is that to the we talked
about the expanding target of
demonization it's not enough to go after
Trump you have to go after his team then
the supporters then the voters and then
anybody who's not part of the resistance
anybody who's breathed
the same air is Trump is vulnerable and
that includes obviously Democrats
because we all share the same oxygen but
I posed a question to liberals who
believe in the First Amendment and
political activism do you want to be
part of a movement that seeks to docs or
punish people because they disagree
politically because that and that goes
nowhere good I mean what are you gonna
have left are you gonna just have like
far left activists running your
businesses you only have like one ice
cream factory in Vermont a lot of real
estate as well as that's true well you
notice I took the bait because I guess
as you know I don't believe in and point
now people who are out there supporting
any candidate but this information is
publicly available it's publicly
available on the websites FEC report is
publicly available I found out this week
when I was home in New Orleans you know
who gave to the governor who didn't give
to the government I'm not going on can
you bring props Donna you always like
have a lot of things are publicly
available but when a congressman puts it
out to his followers on Twitter he wants
something was publicly available first
of all let me just say something Donald
Trump is the biggest Twitter you know
what and the whole wide success story is
that what you not well you know what he
pushes buttons like no one else but this
is not dachshund yesterday you did not
give out the address
I think his intention was to expose
these individuals who had given to the
president under the circumstances also
gave to the Congress and we hear from
one of those people that was on the list
yes you came on television to talk about
what it's like to be the person that was
on that list one absolutely being outed
as a as a contributor wasn't the problem
but tying me to that horrific tragedy in
El Paso was galling and I just think we
all have a right we have in America
right to free speech and I'm and I and a
lot of people that support the president
compliment couldn't be cold we're not
going to be we're not going to be we're
not going to be called racist and the
other slurs without fighting back Dan
what any would think about that you know
Don I disagree it's time to take the El
on this one you just got to take the
loss in admit that this was just dumb
and the dumb test is would you do this
to your opponent I actually ran for
office didn't win but took a shot three
times and the answer is never in a
million years whatever because if
something happened to that person or
their kids because some maniac found
some kind of inspiration in it and
decided to target that person I would
give but when he went away one more
point on this and this public nonsense
oh it's public okay so is my website but
I spent a lot of money to advertise my
website why to make it easier to find
for people putting it out on your
Twitter account with people's names in
their businesses and saying oh well it's
public anyway is the lamest excuse ever
you're making these people easier to
find by advertising I think I think and
unfortunately so I think there will be
more of this the Julian Castro tweet
today was Joaquin and I will keep
fighting the American people will fight
every day for our nation against your
hate your corruption and your ego and
will win hashtag adios Trump I think
that Castro doing that will actually
encourage others to do it because you
could go and find it a hundred percent
and I think here's the bottom line
hate has been associated with
conservatives right now if you're
Republican if you're conservative and
you think about the business but what
about on the local level average day
Americans that have to go this the
University of Texas is going through
this right now the incoming freshmen
class are experiencing daxing if they're
gonna grace you want a conservative
group their information is now being
published their attorney in general for
the state of Texas has now been asked to
get involved by the University of Texas
because this is happening to kids these
were high schoolers right incoming
freshman class their kids and just
because they want to join a conservative
group they're being targeted it's
nonsense
and I think Democrats cozy up to these
type of people that's why when you when
it comes to an tithi they won't do it
many of these policies
go and get in the face of people but
they say well they're hateful people but
would hate become synonymous now in
their eyes of conservatives and
Republicans that becomes a big problem
what about ISM is is what we practice
today when we dislike what the other
side is doing but there's a bigger issue
here the big issue is should we use
social media platform to promote and and
to highlight and amplify hate I said the
other day when we when this first came
out but I would not have done it because
I've been a victim including from
somebody at the very top of our food
chain of using social media platform
calling me out on on false pretenses and
I know what it's like when people come
after you so I'm not for this but what
I'm saying is that this information is
publicly available what the congressman
did I believe has started a nonsense
conversation over the fort you know over
media platforms and how they're they're
being weaponized today I don't believe
in it and I don't believe this is just a
you know another case of a congressman
trying to get attention this was a
stupid idea in a week when we're trying
to focus on the healing of our kind I
think I mean the point you make is is
truth like you don't want to make this
week any worse than it is and so every
people should wake up in the morning and
go okay is what I'm about to do gonna
make it better or worse and I mean
unfortunately a lot of people don't do
that I do think that you know you know
I'll just stop I'm just taking my own
advice a lot of those people were his
donors - yeah what a dopey stupid move
to do remember that test if you wouldn't
do it to your opponent it's probably not
the right thing to do let's just not do
it people let's not Oh